let's take you to july 9 2013.
did there come a time that you went for
a ride on you went to the bahamas and
went on a ride
the yacht with johnny and his kids
it was less like a
we flew out to the bahamas to his island
he was selling the yacht to jk rowling
and he wanted to kind of have a goodbye
trip on the yacht so it was docked off
the island and i went with him
and his
kids who i
had quickly developed a bond with and
loved and
we brought a friend along with us i
think to kind of
help
and
yeah
okay
tell tell the jury what happened on that
trip
johnny was uh upset that he had to sell
the boat
and he was
off the wagon again
but he didn't want to tell his kids so
he was hiding it from them
he was putting it in
coffee cups
and drinking and the behavior just kind
of like he was upset he was emotional
and it just he just
you know that's how he dealt with it
just drink
but there's just no off button with
johnny so he just kept drinking and the
behavior kept getting more obviously
drunk and lily rose his daughter at the
time was young just like maybe 14
and she started to
um
get panicky
and asked started to ask me questions
about his drinking
lily rose um
started to cry
and
expressed to me that she objection here
you you can't say what she said you can
say you can
tell expressions or observations but you
can't say what lily rose said so lily
rose is crying
and the crying becomes like um
like a panic
like like almost like a panic attack uh
like rapid breathing
crying
lots of questions
and i'm holding her kind of comforting
her and johnny comes in
and within a few
um within a few seconds i realized that
he
you know kind of shifted his attention
on me and then he
seemed very angry
uh
he asked lily rose to leave
lily rose leaves
looks at me leaves crying
and johnny
in
i don't remember the word to use but
starts accusing me of kind of
like telling on him
and
calling him um
uh you know a drunk in front of his kids
i hadn't i hadn't done that
i was actually trying to protect johnny
uh i wasn't it didn't feel like my place
at all to share that with with his
daughter or anyone um at the time other
than adults who might help with it but
not his kids
so
i was trying to tell him i'm i was just
trying to comfort her i was trying to
protect you
he
basically was accusing me of doing this
thing and
of of making them aware of his
that he was drinking again
and he slams me up against the the side
wall of the bedroom of the cat we were
in the bedroom this whole time but up
against the wall of the cabin
and slams me up by my neck
and holds me there for a second and
tells me that he
he could kill me
and that was an embarrassment
i was embarrassing it was embarrassment
this whole thing was a joke all
embarrassment i made him feel sick
and
i'll never forget
i'm i'm
i was
i'm very very
very much in love with this whole family
now
and he's saying i'm embarrassing to him
when i saw lily rose again we get
uh
i won't say what she told me but the
next thing we do is we call for a
helicopter to come and take us off of
the
um boat or off of the island so we leave
the boat go to the
landing um of a a a part of the island
or maybe it was a different you know
island we had to get to to leave when we
we take off i'm holding lily rose in my
i'm
literally holding her under my arm while
she's crying